how it was supposed to be folks i was  supposed to play  good games i was supposed to have fun  not all of this  now i'm just tilted  till to the arena for real  okay i don't think he's playing this  very well  should be crashing through here  there's supposed to be a three though  i'm not sure if it works at the moment  because i didn't go bishop c4  i probably didn't feel like you had a  choice there  okay  queen before  that any  [Music]  i good think so okay we'll just  try and console it then  rook g3 rookie one  rebecca arrows again is rebecca harris  streaming  no i don't think  so you should put we have one screen  left that you can put your opponent's  streams on  that would be fun  with it though yeah you can be like  mutual stream snipers like sniping each  other  yeah she she is streaming  she is she is a very good streamer  cool  okay now i'm obviously  meeting him one  yeah i'm doing well against rebecca  harris and then terribly against others